In the beginning, you do have some initial observation.
>From this initial observation, we derive a hypothesis.
A possible explanation for what you just observed.
If the hypothesis explains your observation, the hypothesis must be useful to make a prediction.
In our example, the initial observation was the apple falling.
The hypothesis would be, well every solid objects falls down and then a prediction would be,
if I take this plate and let it fall, it's going to go straight down towards the floor.
It may also break along the way. This is what 3 years old do.
The experiment means to actually verify the prediction so we take the plate and let it fall.
>From the experiment comes the observation. What do you see?
Well, the plate actually was attracted towards the ground and so you can now go
and check whether what you just observed in your experiment is as predicted
and therefore satisfy the hypothesis and we say it supports the hypothesis
and we then can refine the hypothesis.
Our case line says, we can generalized it towards other objects
and to come up with a more general hypothesis.
If the observation, however, is not in line with your prediction, then the hypothesis is rejected,
and if the hypothesis is rejected, you need to come up with a new hypothesis,
and this cycle going along from hypothesis through prediction through experiment through observation
and gradually refining the hypothesis or coming up with alternatives.
This is something you repeat again and again until your hypothesis
becomes consistent with all observations and has so much predictive power
that it becomes what one calls a theory.
In a theory you repeat the process of refining the hypothesis through prediction, experiment,
observation or creating new hypothesis--again going through the circle again and again and again
until your hypothesis becomes a theory
that is a predictive and comprehensive description of some aspect of reality.